OK, so we've got national polls and state
polls and we have an electoral college system
in the United States.
Doesn't matter if you win the popular vote
in the sense that you can win the popular
vote and lose the election.
As Hillary Clinton did in 2016, you can also
lose the popular vote and win the election.
As Donald Trump did in 2016.
Will, the Trump campaign is looking at the
2020 electoral map and they're panicking because
what they see is really not good.
Now I want to give mine.
So this is getting really interesting and
I want to dig into the data.
But I do feel the need to remind everybody
a lot can change in five months.
Just because this is where things are today
does not mean that this is where things will
be in five months.
Trump could end up winning this reelection
in a huge landslide.
We all need to vote, et cetera.
OK.
Now, there are only so many paths to victory
for any one candidate.
The paths to victory are a little bit different
electorally for Democrats than they are for
Republicans in our Electoral Electoral College
system.
Only some states are in play.
So in November, California and Massachusetts
are going to vote for Joe Biden.
North and South Dakota and Wyoming are going
to vote for Donald Trump.
And once you start kind of crossing off the
blue states, that will definitely go Biden
and the red states, that will definitely go
for Trump.
You start to get a set of what we call battleground
states that are the states more likely to
make a difference in the election.
So Massachusetts has a very small chance of
being the decider between Trump and Biden.
It's going to go to Biden and it is not going
to be the state that influences who gets the
270 electoral votes.
There are states that Trump carried easily
in 2016 where he is not doing so well.
And this presents a real problem for Trump
in his path to 270 electoral votes.
Arizona is a state Trump won in 2016 where
he's not doing well right now.
Georgia is almost certain to still go to Donald
Trump.
But Trump is actually having to spend some
money in Georgia, a state that Republicans
often don't have to spend money in.
We've had these national polls where Trump
is losing to Biden by six, seven, even 11
in the latest Monmouth poll, Monmouth poll
very highly rated by 538 ICOM.
But again, the national picture is one thing.
To get a real sense, you have to look state
by state.
So check out some of these examples.
In 2016, Trump won Arizona by three and a
half.
Biden's up by almost three.
That's a six and a half point swing against
Trump in Arizona, Florida.
Trump won by one point two percent in 2016.
Biden is currently leading by three point
four.
That's almost a five point swing in Florida,
very important state in Iowa.
Trump won by almost 10 and he's up by under
five.
That's a five point swing against Trump in
Iowa.
Ohio, massively important to Republicans.
I'll explain why in a moment.
Trump won by eight in 2016.
Biden is currently leading by one.
And Wisconsin, which was one of that tree,
one of the trio of states that handed the
victory to Trump that were reasonable, states
that Hillary Clinton could have won.
Trump won Wisconsin by half a point last election.
Biden currently winning by three point four.
So Florida and Ohio are massively important
because they have a ton of electoral votes
and because they are often the states that
when a Republican loses them, they end up
losing the election.
So five point swing in Florida, a nine point
swing in Ohio away from Donald Trump.
And here's why it matters.
Go to 270 to win dot.com and start with the
2016 map.
It is really difficult for Trump to have a
path to victory without Ohio.
If only Ohio and Florida flipped to Biden.
Biden wins and it's over.
Doesn't matter what happens in other states.
If Trump keeps Florida but loses Ohio, Biden
can still win by flipping Arizona and Wisconsin,
where he's leading Wisconsin and Michigan,
where he's leading.
Or Michigan and Arizona where he's leading.
Even just Pennsylvania, in addition to getting
Ohio, loses it for Donald Trump.
This is why Ohio is so important for Donald
Trump and has been important for Republican
presidents in general.
Never mind some of these other states.
Now, at the tail end of this, even if Trump
keeps Ohio and Florida, which he's currently
losing, but imagine that Ohio and Florida
go back to Donald Trump and he wins them in
November.
Biden can still win by flipping Wisconsin,
Michigan and Pennsylvania, all of which look
pretty good for him right now.
Or Pennsylvania, Michigan and Arizona.
You get the idea.
Holding every 2016 state is very important
for Trump.
He really can't afford to lose very much.
You can go to 270 to win Acom right now.
Run the combinations yourself.
Now, meanwhile, Trump's disapproval rating
has hit a six month high.
Dating all the way back to November.
Small moves, but still significant to some
degree.
So here's what this means.
Absolutely nothing in terms of whether you
should vote in November.
We've got to keep up the pressure.
Donald Trump.
So here's, I think, the most important point
I want to make.
What Donald Trump has done up until now should
already preclude him from being reelected.
You know, if Trump cures cancer and eliminates
poverty in the next five months, come talk
to me.
And then maybe we'll have a different perspective
from what has already happened.
Donald Trump deserves to be removed.
Now, we have five months during which we need
to keep the pressure up.
If the polls remain as they are, Trump will
lose and we will remove what may be one of
the greatest national electoral errors in
the history of this country.
If the pressure lets up, the economy starts
to sort of look like it might be in recovery.
It's conceivable that Donald Trump will get
himself reelected.
And so this is a snapshot today.
We need to continue and we need to keep it
up.
Make sure you are following the show on Facebook
at Facebook, dot com slash David Pakman.
Shall we have it live streaming on Facebook
as well.
I'll see you there or in just two minutes
on the other side of this break.